my name is kedren bryant
and i'm a recording artist and i'm 13
years old
kedran is a child prodigy i started
singing at the age of five years old
and around seven that's when i really
got serious and started really
practicing and watching videos
in 2019 he won youth male vocalist of
the year
at the gospel choice music awards in
georgia
in 2020 he performed on network
television first of all his voice is
amazing
that's music producer dem joints uh his
voice is
only going to get better he's only going
to get better
and more brilliant as an artist dim has
worked with some of the biggest names in
the music business
including eminem rihanna janet jackson
kanye west and christina aguilera
he's seen their creative processes up
close and knows what top talent sounds
like
and now he's working with kidron the 13
year old contemporary r
b and gospel singer i i like old school
music
so i listen to like um the jackson five
and boys commandants and other groups
and r
b stuff man you just crushed me you said
boys to men was old school
that makes me feel really old so
i know your first love is gospel
and we were hoping that maybe you we
could hear you sing a church
song yes all right man
here we go kedron bryant live on
national geographic
there is
only my love
i love to hear
[Music]
and i love to sing
history is filled with inspiring stories
about astonishing young musicians like
kidron
if you google musical prodigies you'll
get hundreds of hits
there's the 10 year old violinist who
plays with the famous philharmonic
the nine-year-old composing symphonies
and the 11 year old blind jazz pianist
the list goes on and on some of these
prodigies go on to amazing careers
and eventually are recognized as
geniuses like chopin or mozart
and others vanish into history
[Music]
i'm peter gwynne editor-at-large at
national geographic magazine
and this is overheard a show where we
eavesdrop
on the wild conversations we have here
at nat geo and follow them to the edges
of our big weird beautiful world
this month the national geographic
channel series genius returns for a
third season with a look at the life of
aretha franklin
so we decided to delve into the question
of what makes a musical genius
how do their brains work what causes
their creations to have such powerful
effects on listeners
and how does society decide who is a
genius
and who's just talented
more after the break
humans have been recognizing that people
were born with special talents for
millennia
we get the word genius from latin in the
time of ancient rome
each person was born with a genius
that's emeritus psychology professor
dean keith simonton he studies human
intelligence
creativity and greatness at uc davis
and this genius was like your guardian
angel
and this angel followed you around your
entire life
and kind of looked out for you and
essentially define what was unique about
you
and later on it got attached to things
where if you had some
special talent for something special
ability
you're a great carpenter you know you're
a great poet
they would call you a genius but as time
went on
people began raising the bar for exactly
who was considered
a genius and particularly during the
romantic period
in western history the turn genius
was extended to really stellar
achievements
being a carpenter no longer cut it i'm
sorry for that pun
um you had to actually do something
truly outstanding
so someone like michelangelo would be
considered a genius
for example or shakespeare or you know
newton
or on the musical front there's a
youngster in austria
named mozart mozart was actually the
first
child prodigy to ever be studied by a
scientist
really yes he was doing a tour with his
dad
of london when he was eight years old
and people were just blown away by how
well he could perform
[Music]
a scholar went to mozart's apartment to
study him and his father
and one thing was just really kind of
amazing is that he would give him tests
to do
and like he'd give them piano duets
that they'd never seen before and they'd
have to sight read
and and even though eight-year-old
mozart learned how to play the
harpsichord from his dad
he outperformed his father in fact every
one cell he'd give his dad dirty looks
whenever his dad would make mistakes
it was absolutely phenomenal what comes
next
is a career that alters history music
seems to pour out of mozart
symphonies operas concertos string
quartets piano sonatas and more
unlike beethoven and other brilliant
composers of that era
mozart writes music in every major genre
of the day
his creativity and mastery seemed to
know no bounds
but where did alice come from and how is
mozart
different from the other talented
composers of his day
okay so what is going on in mozart's
eight-year-old brain
that's not happening in other
eight-year-old brains
well there's two things here um genius
is both born
and made you know it's not just
something that
um you know you you come out of the womb
and you say give me a harpsichord
right okay uh he came from a musical
family
mozart's father was an accomplished
composer in his own right
but once he realized how talented his
son was he bent over backwards to
support him
he basically says my career is over my
career is to be his manager
right and that's an important key to who
mozart becomes in simonton's research
he's come across several common factors
in the lives of geniuses
one is having a family that recognizes
the child's talent
and cultivates it that's crucial to
future success
mozart's father was a composer who
intensively trained him from a young age
and that brings us to another genius
quality being in the right place at the
right time
the mozart family moves to vienna which
in the 1700s
is ground zero for the music world and
young mozart is surrounded by greatness
there's something called the zeitgeist
or the spirit of the times
in german means spirit of the times or
literally times ghost
and um he lived in a kind of a golden
age
of classical music where you had haydn
and all these other great composers
composing all over the place in all
these courts and in concert halls
and so he had that environment going for
him as well
so you know you put all that together
he was the right person at the right
place at the right time
to accept that kind of of genius
almost like there's a hot house effect
and it's not just music these are the
late 1700s
revolutionary times in both the old and
new worlds
and mozart isn't immune to the political
energy around him
he composes his first great operatic
work the marriage of figaro
in 1786 it tells the story of class
struggle in which servants rebel against
the corrupt masters sexual advances
yeah it's a hot house effect and and
that's why
it's extremely rare to see genius just
come out of nowhere
you know it's just like all of a sudden
there's absolutely no examples of genius
in this particular culture
and then all of a sudden you see
somebody
that is extremely rare for that to
happen
but there's something else simonton
identifies that music geniuses need
opportunity to show their talent you see
it was actually another prodigy in the
mozart family one you've probably never
heard of
maria anna mozart was reportedly as
talented as her younger brother
if not more the siblings performed
together
and maria anna was frequently billed
first
but once she reached marriageable age
her family forbade her from touring
she made musical compositions but
they've been lost
and she's largely forgotten
[Music]
so we've looked at how geniuses are
cultivated but where does the original
talent come from
that special gift that is shaped and
developed
what's happening in the brain of a
musical genius
so i run a lab called the sound and
music perception lab at uc san francisco
and we were very lucky to receive a
grant from the national endowment for
the arts
to look at the brain mechanisms of
creative
geniuses you know musical geniuses
that's charles lim
he's an otolaryngologist at uc san
francisco
which means he's a hearing specialist
one of the things he studies
is how the brains of creative geniuses
work especially musical geniuses
we hesitate to use that terminology
because as i said as scientists we don't
even know how to
define what it means to be a genius but
what we're looking for is statistical
outliers
you know people who if you just look at
the statistics of what they're doing and
kind of the how singularly unique
you know there's some musicians where
you just think oh wow this is hard to
believe
and it's those artists that we're trying
to identify and
bring them into the lab and scan their
their brains while they're doing musical
things
lim has examined lots of impressive
musicians
we were able to scan the brain of
gabriella montero the amazing venezuelan
pianist who can improvise an entire
classical music concert you know night
after night she does the second half of
her programs is often fully improvised
from a theme from the crowd
he has his subjects go into an mri
machine
and then he watches their brain activity
while they're composing music
when a highly trained artist
goes into a spontaneous creative mode
that they are shutting off certain parts
of their brain
trained musicians were able to suppress
the parts of their brains that
criticized themselves
and they were also able to go quickly
from having an idea for music
to being able to play that music of
course
that might come from practice rather
than innate talent
it's hard to figure out how or even if
genius brains are actually intrinsically
different
the reason why i'm tiptoeing a little
bit here is because
i would never say we're gonna find the
answers what i would say is we're gonna
try to get closer to the truth
and that truth seems to center around
this this is where i think your history
your memories your self-consciousness
your pathos
your humanity your humility all of these
things i think ultimately impact
that it's a filter and the the music
that's coming out of you is going
through the filter of who you are
channel through your body
[Music]
so we've identified some of the tools in
the genius toolkit
but plenty more are shrouded in mystery
so now it's time to dig a little deeper
by examining a musician who had all
these tools and then some
the queen of soul herself aretha
franklin
that's what the second half of our show
is about looking at how aretha franklin
became a genius
a lot of geniuses have origin stories
little mozart
famously played for emperor franz the
first
and aretha franklin's story involved yet
another famous musician
aretha grew up in detroit smokey
robinson who would go on to become a
renowned motown musician himself
lived just down the street and he was
friends with one of aretha's brothers
one day he went into the franklin family
home and he heard a voice
singing he followed the sound of the
music
and found six-year-old aretha he was
completely dumbfounded by her skill
a lot of stars have to align to create a
musical genius
and aretha franklin very easily could
have been another bright talent that
just never rose out of obscurity
but aretha like mozart had a father who
was totally devoted to her
success reverend c.l franklin
was one of the most famous gospel
preachers in the country
and he wanted to make his daughter an
even bigger deal
i think he was really blown away
by the talent that she had right and
knew
that he needed to nurture it very early
that's mark anthony neal
a professor of african and african
american studies at duke university
mark says aretha's dad trained her he
filled the house with mentors
part of his job was make sure that she
was surrounded by some of the best
musicians
gospel and otherwise that she could be
you got folks like donna washington um
you've got ella fitzgerald
you know reverend james cleveland who
himself is no more than a teenager is
living in the house with them
that's something aretha and mozart had
in common when aretha was in her early
teens
her father took her on the gospel
circuit with him where she performed for
huge audiences
given the way that she was bred and
raised
and nurtured in this environment you
know there was no way she wasn't going
to become what she became
right i would argue that you know she is
someone
who went through the most elaborate
finishing school
of any musician another important trait
geniuses often share is experiencing
trauma
when aretha franklin was 10 her mother
died
suddenly of a heart attack it struck her
with
an immense very deep deep deep
sadness that's deneen l brown
a national geographic writer who wrote
about aretha franklin for the magazine
it just left her with this deep source
of pain that her family and her siblings
often said was never
healed you'd think a tragic event like
that could have thrown off aretha's
singing career
or at least distracted her for a while
but what if the experience of losing a
parent
as horrible as that is acted as a
catalyst
and helped develop her talent the idea
of the tortured artists
and and the artist going through all
sorts of trauma
has some truth to it they are more
likely to
lose one or both parents at a very young
age
it's not that artistic geniuses need
suffering specifically
but something has to throw their lives
off the normal track
and for an artist that's extremely
important
if you if you don't have a different
perspective to take on the world
then what are you going to do your art
about
the year her mother died aretha was
scheduled for her first solo performance
at church
she gets up looking like a lost child
you know she clearly had a kind of
sadness in her eyes aretha stands behind
the piano
looking out over a crowd of congregants
she pauses
her sister who's sitting in the audience
worries that aretha won't be able to
perform
aretha has been an emotional wreck all
week crying constantly
and then she starts singing
and to everyone's surprise it's not
terrible it's not even
fine it's great
she somehow sings gospel that's filled
with blues
that sadness transformed
itself in her voice and the way she was
able to compose
and empower
songs and
transmit the sadness into something else
that could connect to audiences
[Music]
and that special ability would turn out
to be incredibly important for her time
and place
[Music]
aretha appeared on the scene during an
explosion of black musical culture
remember how we talked about mozart
coming onto the scene during europe's
political upheaval
and in the midst of its golden classical
music moment
well in the 1960s motown was taking off
the radio waves were filled with new
black voices
but it wasn't just music the civil
rights movement is building momentum
protests are popping up with more
frequency and fervor
and aretha is coming of age as an
independent woman
and as an artist right in the middle of
all that creative energy
dr martin luther king jr would come
visit her father's church in detroit
and then come to her house
after church for dinner one of her most
famous songs respect became so
famous because her audience could relate
to it
okay so sometimes music is used in
revolutions to
to transmit messages right aretha
franklin's voice
embodied this revolutionary period
in the united states where black people
were in the streets demanding respect
black comedian and activist dick gregory
said that on the radio
you'd hear aretha three or four times an
hour you'd only hear king on the news
[Music]
aretha's legacy could have stopped right
there a dominant voice
cresting on the wave of r b and civil
rights
and then gracefully receding as the
tides of history shift
but there's something else geniuses tend
to have in common
when they master a field they ask
what can i try next you're just willing
to try out different things you'll try
out different foods
you're open to different cultures you
are open to different values you may
explore different religious beliefs
and that's what moves them beyond what
other people have done
and into new possibilities so how does
aretha compare
okay aretha started in gospel became a
gospel superstar
and then could have stayed in gospel
forever but like mozart composing in all
the genres of his day
aretha explores all sorts of styles r
b soul pop aretha's target is that
she could sing anything that you put in
front of her
and eventually master whatever genre
it belonged to but there's one poignant
moment that occurs
late in her career that showed her range
in a way
few could have anticipated and in the
minds of many critics
seals her legacy as a unique musical
genius
okay so it's the 1998 grammys luciano
pavarotti
a classically trained opera star is set
to sing the puccini
arya nesundorma for a tv audience of
millions
but the unthinkable happens pavarotti
gets sick
30 minutes after the grammys begin he
calls the show's producers and says he
can't perform
backstage it's total chaos the producers
are scrambling to find some way out of
this disaster
aretha happens to be performing at the
grammys too and a producer gets an idea
let's ask her to sing nest and dorma so
he runs to aretha's dressing room
pops the cassette into a boom box and
plays the song for her
and says hey can you sing this like
on stage now she said
you know i'll do it okay so
the audience has already watched her
sing respect with danicroid and the
other members of the blues brothers
doing the backing vocals
no big surprise the queen of soul doing
her special thing right
but they don't know this is coming
and sting steps onto the stage and
informs the crowd
that pavarotti is sick but that a friend
has agreed to step in at a moment's
notice
and then ladies and gentlemen aretha
franklin
but when she walks out on stage you can
hear audibly
in the crowd this heightened sense of
expectation because they
really don't know what's about to happen
they don't know
what this is going to sound like
[Music]
she crushes it of course aretha doesn't
speak italian but she imbues the lyrics
with palpable emotion
the music has been arranged in a key
that's suited specifically to
pavarotti's voice
but aretha adjusts her voice to match it
crowd gasps and cries out as she powers
through the notes
at the end gives her a standing ovation
it's a performance only a musical genius
could pull off
we've linked to the video in the show
notes if you want to see it for yourself
it is awe inspiring so
here's aretha franklin who's the queen
of
soul you know singing this arya
so it wasn't just one thing that made
aretha a genius
it was a confluence of very specific
rare ingredients
that came together at a precise moment
in history
aretha could have only happened at the
time that she happened
because of all these forces
how i loved you
jesus and it's all
how i loved you
jesus
so what about kidron he may have some of
the raw ingredients for genius
but can he ride at the front of the
current cultural wave
during the george floyd protest this
summer kedron's mom wrote a song about a
young black man fearing for his life
kidron read the lyrics and prayed on
them trying to focus
you have to get in the mindset of you
just you just can't go on and start
singing about a killing of racism in the
world
and and and then you're thinking about
rainbows and
and candyland and stuff like that
he recorded himself singing the song and
then posted it to instagram
and that's how dem joints his producer
discovered him
dim was watching tv when his girlfriend
played kedron's video on her phone
dim overheard it and you know how
certain things you're either watching
something or you're listening to uh
something
and uh it gives you that moment to where
it hits you in the gut
you know what i mean totally it was his
voice
and the pain uh it sounded that went
along with his
voice and his message i didn't know who
the kid was
but i felt like i wanted to be a part of
that
dim takes the video and mixes kidron's
voice with music
and then gets in touch with kidron and
his family
meanwhile the video goes totally viral
we included a link in the show notes
warner records and dim joints label you
made us what we are
sign key drawn to a record deal
so i was at my house and um they called
my mom's phone
and um told them and my mom was like
who's this
and then it said jay-z and and we just
all started screaming
and then um beyonce said and beyonce so
then we were like oh my gosh
wow and so he was like me like running
around and then
so immediately you start singing a lot
of jay-z and beyonce songs and right
yes the question's got to be like hey
jay-z let's do a collab
right well i didn't ask him but i
definitely
um want to do a collab with him
all right jay-z if you're listening
national geographic is offering up its
studios
for you and kedron to do a do a collab
so
if kidron wants to reach genius he's
going to need that perfect storm of
nature
nurture and luck
jay-z balls in your court
[Music]
of course there's a whole lot more to
the queen of soul and if you want to
learn more about her extraordinary life
check out our magazine story in the
april issue of national geographic
and also we feature her in the new
season of genius
on national geographic also
we've got links to hear the song that
made kidron famous
and the opera performance that cemented
aretha's genius
that's all in the show notes they're
right there in your podcast app
[Music]
overheard at national geographic is
produced by alana strauss
ryan gutierrez jacob pinter laura sim
and carlo wills our senior editor is eli
chen
our executive producer of audio is dvar
arlen
our fact checkers are julie beer and
robin palmer our copy editor is amy
kolczak
hansdale sue sound designed this episode
and composed our theme music
this podcast is a production of national
geographic partners
whitney johnson is the director of
visuals and immersive experiences
susan goldberg is national geographic's
editorial director
and i'm your host peter gwynne and
that's all for this season
but amy and i will be back soon with
more new episodes
thanks for listening and see y'all soon
[Music]
you